Here are some upcoming panels,
and you should pay attention,
that still have short lines.
Very short lines, if
you wanna check 'em out.
On Sunday, there's
The Guy Who Made the Shawarma
for The Avengers Tells All.
You wanna check that one out.
(laughter)
Yeah, you wanna see that one.
(cheering)
Check this one out, there's
Meet the Last Four Actors Who
Haven't Played Spider-Man.
(laughter)
Yeah, yeah.
(applause)
There's this one,
Klingon Genitalia: A Closer Look.
(laughter)
Check out this one, there's
A Tribute to Stan Lee's Greatest Typos
Featuring The Silver Suffer.
(laughter)
C'mon, my dad wrote that one.
And then there's
(laughter)
The Cast of the Guardians of The Galaxy
If it Starred Different
People Such as Emilio Estevez,
(laughter)
Emilio Estevez Not Available.
(cheering and applause)
Very short line.
There's When Hulk Smash, Are You Covered?
What You Need to Know About
Superhero Liability Insurance.
(laughter and applause)
And finally, my favorite,
Ron Perlman Will Glare
At You for 30 Seconds.
(laughter and cheering)
I would go to that one.
[Andy] I would do that.